for somebody to do what you do
and to sit there and get the constant
criticism to tough questions is that
duplicatable
or is that just purely uh uh in the
individual's psyche DNA that maybe
somebody can get a little bit better uh
in the area of answering the tough
questions but there's got to be a part
of it that's your personality your
temperament to do that because that's
not an easy job specifically during the
time that you did it that's a very very
difficult time to do that do you think
someone can learn how to do that or some
of that is natural
I think a lot of it is temperament you
have to one enjoy the Press you really
do you have to look at that briefing
room as a fun place to stand your ground
and you have to respect the fact that
under our first amendment the Press can
ask whatever damn well pleases and
that's their job and just because you
get asked a hard question doesn't mean
you have to struggle you can give a hard
answer and return sometimes you can give
a fun answer in Return of poke fun at
reporters it's just how you do it but
what it comes down to is enjoying it
respecting the process respecting the
Press but standing your ground on behalf
of what you believe in and what the
president is advocating for that's what
makes the job really fun how much of it
do you uh is it like anticipation you
take out you know like you see the
current one you know it's a whole folder
you know and sacky and many of these
that they have these okay what question
are you asking okay I got eight seconds
to go to the page yeah on what it is and
then they just read it oh would you ask
okay can you go into it over here no let
me see what he said how much of it is
preparation to say uh uh like are you
sitting with a group of people saying
okay guys what do you think they're
going to be asking us Ari they're going
to ask about this okay let's role play
if they ask you this what's your answer
going to be I'm probably going to say
something this avoid that word say this
I wouldn't say that that will attack you
if you say this and then which which
ones are we working on we're looking at
all these people you know those three
can't stand you you know those three uh
ask softball questions you know those
three you like but they ask tough
questions is I'm assuming all of it
you're a sports guy I'm assuming their
strategy to the madness as well no there
is but there's also fundamentals go back
to sports if your swing's no good it
doesn't matter how much time you take be
pay if your mechanics are wrong you're
not gonna be able to improve that much
the single the most important way to
handle that job you can't speak for the
president if you don't listen to the
president so the way to prep is you got
to be in the Oval Office all the time I
was in almost all the president's
meetings I'd spend a third a quarter of
my day in the oval listening to what he
listened to hearing what he said and
then you take that so now you've got
knowledge you know what the president's
doing then you take that and yeah you do
get your staff before you go out and
prep before you brief and you say fire
away what are they going to ask me today
and sometimes go okay I got that one I
got it I got it got it all right whoa
let's talk about that one that one's a
curveball what are we going to say on
that one call the Secretary of Defense I
need to answer on this call the pr
spokesman spokesperson at the Department
of Transportation get me more info so it
all goes into it but again
the essential ingredient to surviving
that room is having fun you know I
looked at it like it was intellectual
chess I'd go in there going if I say a I
can make them ask question B and I was
already thinking of answers you see
knowing I could take them to question
yeah and I thrived on that
um go back to sports that room was my
field and I was never going to let the
Press beat me on my field and so I
looked at it like a sport like
competition knowing what questions they
were going to ask because you'd try to
anticipate it sure so my hardest stays
frankly
were slow newsdays if there was a major
crisis if something was terrible going
on on September 11th I knew every
question was going to be about what did
Bush do what did Bush said yeah
September 11th
frankly from just a briefing point of
view those days were simpler and easier
wow because I knew every question coming
and I knew the answers
the slow news days nothing's really big
nothing's going on I don't know what 25
topics that's the hardest what a great
perspective to think about so it is more
predictable the the more crisis there is
because you know what this 80 percent of
questions are going to be and the less
crisis there is you don't know what's
going to be Adam thanks for joining us
I'm glad you made it thank you sir
Howard how are your appointments tonight
I uh the retirement community sends
their love especially to you Mr
Fleischer from Love from uh down in
Miami but yeah of the two of us I
guarantee you had a more wild night than
I did I guarantee that really did
the way you say that I mean some people
are going to say Pat's married how Wild
of a night did he have you had dinner at
an amazing place I had a good dinner I
came home and I I even text you and I'm
like this place is wild I gotta leave
but uh yes but going back well tomorrow
but going back to it what you said very
important uh uh question so you said hey
I'm I was never gonna let them beat me
right at their game and you know
give me your biggest victory during that
time and and the day that they maybe
whooped your butt a little bit what
would be the two you know
the biggest quote-unquote victory was
after September 11th in the lead-up to
the war in Afghanistan I'll never forget
this there was a front page story in USA
Today saying Special Forces deployed to
Afghanistan and this is before the first
shot was fired before anything took
place
and your special forces and the Army the
Army I almost went into special I
thought you were a ranger I was a 101st
Airborne Arab is what I was yeah okay
well I interviewed you're very closely
of Special Forces I was down the street
from them yes that's what if I would
have reenlisted I would have gone into
Special Forces so the story was special
for us as Rangers deployed to
Afghanistan and live at the briefing and
this briefing is covered on live TV
everywhere Al Jazeera is covering it
live I get asked to confirm whether or
not we sent Special Forces but over the
ground troops before the Before the War
Began
and I looked at the reporter and I said
you know under our system you have the
right to ask me anything you want
I have the responsibility not to answer
next question
and I kind of feel America cheering for
me when I said that answer
because yeah the Press is going to ask
for deployment information they want to
know about the movement of our ships and
our troops in advance of a war
as if I'm going to tell them anything of
course I'm not going to tell him
anything
but it's such a funny dichotomy because
every reporter in the room was pissed at
me how come you won't answer that
question but I knew everybody in America
was cheering for me because they didn't
want me to answer that question and
that's when it was just so crystal clear
to me that my job sometimes is to speak
over the heads of reporters and say what
the president wanted me to say to the
people and that's that was in many ways
my you know called it Victory so what
all the craziness taking place I believe
future looks right if you believe future
looks bright get your latest Future
looks bright hat of valuetainment it
says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
our black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody saying future looks
spread toward your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]